>> Tammy: IT'S THURSDAY AND WE
HAVE A SPECIAL EDITION OF
THURSDAY FOLLIES.
TAYLOR SWIFT IS COMPARING
HERSELF TO A FIRST LADY.
PROTEST SONGS GO HAYWIRE.
HOLLYWOOD CANNOT GET ENOUGH OF
REBOOTS.
JOINING US NOW WITH ALL OF THE
DETAILS IS THE ONLY GUY WHO CAN
GIVE THEM TO US, RAYMOND ARROYO,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
YOU HAVE NOTICED A DISTURBING
NEW STYLE OF PROTEST SONGS
EMERGING ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WHAT THE HECK IS GOING ON?
>> I HAVE INDEED, TAMMY.
PROTEST SONGS GO BACK CENTURIES
AND THEY USUALLY ARE CATCHY
DUTIES WITH THE POLITICAL EDGE.
"IF I HAD A HAMMER," OR "BLOWING
IN THE WIND."
SOME EXAMPLES SHOW THAT THE
GENRE IS CLEARLY IN BIG TROUBLE.
FOR INSTANCE, IN TUCSON,
ARIZONA, PAIR LADIES NOW KNOWN
AS THE SINGING SANCTUARY SISTERS
STOOD UP AT A LOCAL HEARING
AND URGE THAT THEIR TOWN
BECOME A SANCTUARY CITY AND THEY
MADE THEIR PLEA IN A SONG OF
THEIR OWN COMPOSITION.
>> ♪♪ WE ALL KNOW THE RIGHT
THING AIN'T NO MORE DEPORTATION
DEPORTATIONS, THEY SAW BROKEN
TAIL LIGHTS ♪
♪ SAFETY FOR ALL ♪
♪ IT MEANS THAT DUE PROCESS ♪
♪ IS A PART OF OUR CHARTER ♪
♪ PROTECTED FROM PARTISAN AND
POLITICAL NITWITS ♪
♪ ALL OVER THIS STATE ♪♪
>> [LAUGHS]
TAMMY, I THINK WE NEED TO SEND
THEM A METRONOME AND A RHYMING
DICTIONARY.
THIS WAS THE MOST TORTURED
PROTEST SONG I THINK I'VE EVER
HEARD.
SCARY.
♪♪ IF I HAD TALENT ♪
♪ I'D WRITE A SONG ♪
♪ IF YOU'D LIKE MY TALENT ♪
♪ YOU COULD SING WITH ME ♪♪
THEY LABORED TO NOT RHYME.
>> Tammy: IT FRIGHTENS ME THAT
THAT MAY AFFECT BE THE RESULT OF
THE FEMINIST MOVEMENT.
AND I'M VERY DISTURBED.
I AM HONORED TO BE ABLE TO GUEST
HOST HERE AND SEE YOU.
BUT I DON'T KNOW IF I'LL EVER
THINK OF YOU IN THE SAME WAY,
RAYMOND.
>> I THINK I CAN TOP IT.
STAY RIGHT THERE.
NOT ONLY AMATEURS, TAMMY, BUT
EVEN PROFESSIONAL, LEGENDARY
SINGERS JUST CAN'T SEEM TO GET
THE PROTEST SONG RIGHT.
BARBRA STREISAND, SHE RECORDED A
WHOLE ALBUM THIS YEAR TO PROTEST
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
AT HER CONCERT AT
MADISON SQUARE GARDEN LAST
WEEKEND, SHE TURNED HER "HAND IN
THE CLOUDS" TO A PROTEST SONG
RETITLED "WHO IS THIS CLOWN?"
YOU CAN GUESS WHO THAT WAS ABOU
ABOUT.
>> ♪♪ HIS ART OF THE DEAL ♪
♪ SOME AWFUL JOKE ♪
♪ YOU GOT TO ADMIT ♪
♪ THIS FRAUDULENT TWIT ♪
♪ IS SO FULL OF [BLEEP] ♪♪
>> OH, TAMMY, THIS IS PAINFUL.
I CAN'T EVEN LISTEN TO IT.
>> Tammy: IT'S A SHAME.
SHE'S A GREAT PERFORMER.
SHE HAS A GREAT VOICE.
AND SHE'S RUNNING THINGS, WHICH
I NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD EVER
SAY.
>> IT'S DIVISIVE.
PEOPLE PAY MONEY, PARTICULARLY
TO SEE SOMEONE LIKE
BARBRA STREISAND, THEY WANT TO
RELIVE THE MEMORIES AND HEAR THE
MUSIC AND ENJOY THE MEMORY OF
WHAT WAS AND WHAT IS.
WHAT SHE DOES BY POLITICIZING IT
SHE TAINTS THE WHOLE AFFAIR AND
THE SAD PART IS I REMEMBER WE
WENT TO SEE HER AT THE
VERIZON CENTER.
I TOOK MY WIFE AND MY WIFE SAID
IF SHE GETS POLITICAL I'M GOING
OUT TO GET A DRINK.
MY WIFE NEVER LEFT THE BAR,
TAMMY, THE WHOLE TWO HOURS.
NEVER LEFT THE BAR.
IT'S SAD TO WATCH THIS BUT IF
YOU'RE GOING TO DO A PROTEST
SONG, BE CLEVER.
THIS WASN'T.
SINCE WE ARE SPEAKING ON
RETREADS, THIS WEEK WE ALSO SAW
SERIES OF REBOOTS IT'S
BREATHTAKING EVEN BY HOLLYWOOD
STANDARDS.
IT'S NOT JUST THAT THEY ARE OUT
OF IDEAS.
IT TELLS US SOMETHING ABOUT
WHERE WE ARE AS A CULTURE AND AS
A PEOPLE.
THERE IS YET ANOTHER "ADAMS
FAMILY" MOVIE, THE 90210 REBOOT
HIT THE AIRWAVES THAT FOX
AND DISNEY JUST ANNOUNCED ITS
RELAUNCHING "NIGHT AT THE
MUSEUM" AND "HOME ALONE."
ONLY ONE PROBLEM: GOOGLE
RELAUNCHED "HOME ALONE" IN AN AD
LAST YEAR WITH THE ORIGINAL CAS
CAST.
>> SOMEONE IS AT THE FRONT DOOR.
>> WHAT DO I OU?
>> LOOKS LIKE YOU PAID ONLINE.
>> Tammy: RAYMOND, MACAULAY
CULKIN ACTUALLY HAS WEIGHED IN
ON THE REBOOT ANNOUNCEMENT.
>> HE DID.
HE POSTED THIS PICTURE, OR
TWEETING "THIS IS WHAT AN
UPDATED "HOME ALONE" WOULD LOOK
LIKE."
HE SAID HE DISNEY, CALL ME.
I GUESS IF THE 90210 KIDS CAN
REBOOT THEIR ROLES, WHY NOT
KEVIN McALLISTER?
>> Tammy: YOU ALSO THINK,
SINCE WERE TALKING ABOUT
REBOOTS, FOR ME IT'S A LACK OF
CREATIVITY.
WE ARE SEEING SO MANY.
WHAT DO THEY TELL US ABOUT THE
CULTURE IN GENERAL?
>> I THINK THEY TELL US FIRST OF
ALL THERE'S A LOVE OF NOSTALGIA.
PEOPLE WANT TO GO BACK BECAUSE I
THINK THEY ARE SO TRAUMATIZED BY
THE PRESENT SCENE, BY WHAT
THEY'RE SAYING NOW.
THE DANGEROUS THING IS BY GOING
BACK, THAT BEGINS TO DEFINE THIS
ERA.
THIS HAS BECOME THE REBOOT
RETREAD RERUN ERA.
WE HAD THE KNEE ERA.
THIS IS THE RE ERA, AND I'M
WORRIED.
>> Tammy: TIME FLIES WHEN WERE
HAVING FUN BUT I HAVE TO GET
YOUR REACTION TO THIS INTERVIEW
WITH TAYLOR SWIFT.
SHE COMPARED HERSELF TO A
FIRST LADY.
WHO WAS IT?
>> HILLARY CLINTON.
SHE SAID SHE COULDN'T ENDORSE
HILLARY IN THE LAST CAMPAIGN
BECAUSE "THE SYMBOL FOR THAT
ELECTION, ALL PEOPLE WERE SAYING
WAS SHE'S CALCULATED, SHE'S MINI
GLITTER.
SHE'S NOT WHAT SHE SEEMS.
SHE'S A SNAKE, LIAR.
THESE ARE THE SAME EXACT INSULT
PEOPLE WERE HURLING AT HILLARY.
WHAT I BE AN ENDORSEMENT OR
LIABILITY?
SNAKES OF A FEATHER FLOCK
TOGETHER.
LOOK AT THE LYING WOMEN, THE
NASTY WOMEN.
SEEMS TO ME SWIFT'S CRITICS MAY
BE RIGHT.
SHE WAS CALLOUSLY CALCULATING
HOW TO KEEP HER HILLARY
ENDORSEMENT UNDER WRAPS AND THE
LAST TIME SHE ENDORSED ANYBODY
SHE FLAMED OUT.
SHE ENDORSED THE DEMOCRATS
AGAINST MARSHA BLACKBURN AND
TENNESSEE.